foreign
hi guys it's Quinn here and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the YouTube algorithm really notices
me in my last video on the culture
series I said that if you haven't read
the books just to pick up consider
fleebus and see if you like it this was
my experience because I read the books
in the typical suggested order but I
guess you don't really have to read the
books in any kind of order in fact
consider fleebus really provides you
with mainly just an outsider's view on
the culture other books in this series
like the player of games and use of
weapons provide a more complete view of
the culture because the main characters
are members of the culture itself I
think accession book five is probably
the best book all together along with
the player of games coming up as a close
second if you've watched my last video
because I was attempting to provide a
quick overview for people who have not
read the series at all and wanted to
uncover the nuances of the culture for
themselves you might have gotten the
impression that the culture's defining
feature is its technology but in reality
it's not just about tech it's about what
the culture represents and quite frankly
the culture of the culture this video
will have some minor spoilers for the
various culture books and short stories
so keep that in mind
the culture actually existed for many
thousands of years before it potentially
revealed itself to humanity on Earth and
there is a reason that I say potentially
and I'll get to that in just a second
and Banks's collection of short stories
the state of the art it is revealed in
the novella of the same title that the
culture had actually visited Earth
sometime in the late 1970s and had been
studying Humanity
by the spring of the Year 1977 A.D the
general contact unit arbitrary had been
stationed above the planet Earth for the
best part of six months
the ship of the escarpment class middle
series had arrived during the previous
November after clipping the edge of the
planet's expanding electromagnetic
emission shell while on what it claimed
was a random search how random the
search pattern was I don't know the ship
might well have had some information it
wasn't telling us some scrap of rumor
half remembered from somebody's long
discredited archives multitudinously
translated and re-transmitted vague and
uncertain after all that time and
movement and change just a mentioned
that there was an intelligent human-ish
species there or at least the beginnings
of one or the possibility of one
this being said it's not exactly clear
where exactly the humans of Earth
actually fit into the culture the
culture may have made contact with the
humans of Earth and assimilated them but
it has never stated when or if this
happened in fact it is not clear if any
humans descended from those of Earth are
part of the culture at all this implies
several things the humans of the culture
and the humans of Earth could share a
common ancestor perhaps the Earth humans
had been seeded there in the state of
the art the Earth humans are described
as human-ish meaning not quite human as
far as the culture was concerned this
indicated that the humans of Earth were
still evolving and it not quite yet
reached the level of humanness that was
familiar to the culture
in his published essay a few notes on
the culture Banks mentions that the
culture was originally formed from a
collection of about eight humanoid
species approximately 9 000 years before
the modern culture age these original
groups Allied in order to gain
independence from the governmental and
political structures in which they had
themselves evolved from in the book The
hydrogen Sonata it is mentioned that the
original suggested name for the newly
formed group was the aliens But
ultimately they chose the culture
instead
in the book to look Windward which is
basically a sequel to consider fleebus
though they weren't published back to
back it mentions that by the 22nd
century there were about 31 trillion
citizens of the culture scattered widely
through the Galaxy on ships planets but
mainly orbitals similar to but not
exactly the same as the ring world and
Larry Nevin's series the culture didn't
really like to terraform planets because
they were more interested in preserving
things rather than destroying them the
book surface detail confirms that there
are at least 50 billion citizens of the
culture by the 29th century
for the trillions of biological life
forms of the culture death was sometimes
avoidable altogether they were
genetically perfect essentially
possessing no defects they could live up
to 400 years all the while experiencing
none of the effects of Aging until the
very end and those who did not wish to
die at all could be rejuvenated or
essentially live an eternity in one of
the culture's storage facilities as
mentioned in the book accession but
these were far from the only options
every culture habitat whether it was an
orbital or other large structure a ship
a rock or a planet possessed storage
facilities
storage was where some people went when
they had reached a certain age or if
they had just grown tired of living it
was one of the choices that culture
humans faced towards the end of their
artificially extended three and a half
to four centuries of Life they could opt
for Rejuvenation and or complete
immortality they could become a part of
a group mind they could simply die when
the time came they could transferred out
of the culture altogether bravely
accepting one of the open but
essentially inscrutable invitations left
by certain Elder civilizations or they
could go into storage with whatever
Revival Criterion they desired some
people slept for say a hundred years at
a time and then lived a single day
before returning to their undreaming
unaging Slumbers some wanted to simply
be woken after a set time had passed to
see what had changed while they had been
gone some desire to come back when
something especially interesting was
happening content to leave that to the
Judgment of others and some only want it
to be brought back if and when the
culture had finally become one of the
elders itself
the universe in which the culture series
takes place is a universe that is much
lived in there are countless
civilizations which have lived and died
and there are of course Elder races
which have retreated from interactions
with greater Cosmic Society altogether
it is also mentioned in accession that
the culture has been putting off the
decision to Sublime and become one of
the Elder Civilizations for millennia
another thing that's very interesting
about the culture is that they don't
really have laws this is one of the many
things that makes the post-scarcity
society presented in the culture series
different from the ones presented in
things like Star Trek any rules that the
culture has relates to restricting
Freedom or causing harm to others if
anyone is really bad they have a drone
follow you around and prevent you from
doing anything bad again they call these
slap drones
we have these things called slap drones
oh yes she had vaguely heard of drones
they were the culture's equivalent of
robots though they looked more like
items of luggage than anything else some
of the tinier things floating in the
great hazy view in front of them were
probably drones
she already didn't like the idea of a
variety with the word slap in its title
they're things that stop people doing
something they probably ought not do
since you told her they just accompany
you she Shrugged sort of an escort if it
thinks you're about to do something
objectionable like hit somebody or try
to kill them or something it'll stop you
a slap drone has various methods to stop
a person and ultimately they can render
a person unconscious painlessly of
course the drones also have the
capability to read minds if necessary
though this is considered taboo before
engaging in any kind of force however
the culture will attempt to help a
citizen first if something goes wrong
mentally by offering them voluntary
psychological adjustment most citizens
of the culture however have
well-balanced personalities though in
rare cases some abort traits may appear
the culture is a hedonistic Society they
emphasize pleasure over work even the a
non-biological drones seek pleasure
there is also a form of sex that drones
can engage in with each other for
pleasure drones are about as intelligent
as people and they have their own
individual personalities civilian drones
however are not as smart as drones built
to be agents of contact or special
circumstances these also have powerful
force fields and lasers as well as
perhaps other weapons within the culture
itself there are various variants of
humans interestingly enough most
alterations to the human form go in and
out of style almost like fashion choices
humans can basically change anything
about themselves they can even alter
their sex entirely it is mentioned in
the book accession that some Modern
culture humans like overseech are
descended from humans who had chosen to
take more animalistic forms
overseas had been one of The Rock's
founding families she could trace her
ancestry back through 54 Generations on
phage itself and numbered amongst her
ancestors at least two forebearers who
were inevitably mentioned in even one
volume histories of the culture as well
as being descended from as the Fashions
of the intervening times had ordained
people who had resembled Birds fish
dirigible balloons snakes small clouds
of cohesive smoke and animated bushes
the tenor of the time had generally
turned against such outlandishness and
people had mostly returned to looking
more like people over the last
Millennium albeit assuredly pretty
good-looking people but still some part
of one's appearance was initially at
least left to luck and the random nature
of genetic inheritance and it was a
matter of some pride to over that she
had never had any form of physical
alteration carried out dwell apart from
the neural lace of course but that
didn't count
humans outside the culture who were not
altered in any way are referred to by
members of the culture as human basic
some altered humans don't look like
humans at all they choose to take the
form of other beings perhaps not even
humanoid but it is also mentioned in the
book matter that if the form is too
different from the human form that the
process could be irreversible one thing
I find really interesting about the
culture is their relationship with drugs
in the Dune series one of my favorites
of all time the relationship between the
progress of humanity and the use of
drugs is a pretty significant part of
the series the culture series takes this
to a new level and this series any human
with the proper glands can access drugs
anytime they want these glands produce
these substances from within their own
bodies the drugs have various uses
whether sensory sexual or mind enhancing
just a few of the drugs mentioned in the
series include sharp blue which is
essentially a drug that heightens
problem-solving capability or spark
which is mentioned in the book matter as
a drug that can release you from a dark
mood and then there's snap which is
referred to as a breakfast drug and the
book player of games he forced himself
awake glanding the culture's favorite
breakfast drug snap and was a little
disappointed to see Ram look just as
fresh and energetic as he felt snap was
a mood enhancer it also seemed to
increase alertness and energy and there
are several more drugs named in the
series that do different things
in this series Ian Banks is toying with
our conception of what humanity is it is
never quite clear even what the culture
means when it says humanoid or human
what is the criteria for humans what is
the hidden quality that is distinct to
humanity the quality that defines us I
think banks never quite went into detail
about this perhaps ultimately because it
doesn't matter Humanity will always be
in a state of constant Evolution
constant change and even when we take
the Reigns of our own Evolution it still
won't account for individual Choice
humans will still change themselves
simply because they can instead of based
on the need to adapt I plan on talking
more about certain aspects of the
culture series and future videos let me
know what other science fiction series
you'd like to see me explore in the
comments section below thank you guys
just a heads up for those of you that
may be interested my next graphic novel
the LIE behind the star is launching
February 2023 you can sign up now to get
on the email mailing list to get
notified as soon as it launches more
information on my website link in the
description thank you guys so much
[Music]